i've lost my job my emma has been lost
her job because of this school video i
lost my job we lost
our jobs the curved 19 pandemic has
widened the gap between rich and poor
in a city with a long history of
inequality
hundreds of thousands of people lost
their jobs when the country went into
lockdown
in march last year many soon found
themselves
hungry and homeless
at least 54 new informal settlements
have since cropped up in and around cape
town
since july 2020 up until middle of may
this year
we have seen in total 1193 land
invasions
across our province of which 1774
invasions
which were successful occurred in the
city of cape town
the impact thereof is devastating
because ultimately we also try to
prevent these invasions
at a cost of oh well over 400 million
authorities say they've been trying to
demolish the shacks before they can be
occupied
but they have been accused of brute
force in their attempts
to prevent illegal land occupations
[Music]
this one nature reserve is now home to
an estimated
twenty thousand dwellings
residents have named their new
settlement covert 19.
when coffee 19 started like a lot of
people lost their jobs
lost their income and some of us were
chased away by where we are renting
and we couldn't afford the rent anymore
so there was this piece of
land that was not used
it like it was a nature reserve and
we're part of the nature because we're
human beings
so we saw the piece of land we just came
to
to erect our structures the government
says
almost two and a half thousand houses
could have been built
with the money spent trying to protect
land
and it accuses what it calls shack
farmers
of selling plots of illegal land to
desperate people
but those living here without water
toilets or electricity say they can
barely afford bread
let alone land robin smith
al jazeera cape town